sap à l'homme dans le centre pour
retrouver les gangsters qui ont tué deux
promeneurs et blessé trois autres
personnes
raymond barre dans les ardennes le
premier ministre a rencontré tous les
syndicats les palestiniens de l'ol paie
accepterait sous condition la résolution
242 de l'onu
bonsoir
la chasse à l'homme continue ce soir
dans la région du puy en velay la haute
loire pour essayer de retrouver les
trois gangsters qui ont tué deux
promeneurs et blessé trois personnes
dont deux gendarmes une poursuite
particulièrement dramatique car les
trois gangsters ils l'ont prouvé sont
capables de tirer froidement sur tous
ceux qui se mettent en travers de leur
chemin
tout avait commencé hier par un hold up
disons classique scénario habituel les
gangsters entre armes au poing dans une
succursale de crédit agricole il
s'empare de 4 millions de centimes en
ferme les témoins et puis il s'enfuit
jusqu'au moment où ils sont interceptés
par les gendarmes là c'est le drame
attention avait dit les gangsters aux
employés du crédit agricole
nous avons la gâchette facile ce qui
n'était au départ qu'un hold up minable
dans un bourg des cévennes s'est
transformée en gigantesque chasse à
l'homme dans plusieurs départements car
dans leur fuite les gangsters ont tué le
premier drame a lieu près de la petite
ville de joyeuse en ardèche complètement
affolé les gangsters tir sur deux
gendarmes qui voulaient les arrêter pour
excès de vitesse
l'un des gendarmes est grièvement
blessée d'une rafale de mitraillette
dans le ventre le deuxième drame se
déroule ici près de bons labeaume où les
gangsters mitraille trois habitants la
région le père le fils et un ami qui ont
eu le malheur de se trouver sur leur
chemin
cyprien malosse c'est son fils qui
rentrait tranquillement chez eux sont
tués à bout portant leurs passagers
échappe par miracle à la fusillade
ajoutez à cette cavale sanglante un
autre blessé un simple promeneur
renversé par la voiture des gangsters
celle ci a été retrouvé ce matin à 15 km
du puits à la faveur de la nuit et des
routes de montagne les deux gangsters
avaient donc réussi à échapper aux
barrages
quatre à cinq cents gendarmes ratissent
actuellement la région avec chiens et
hélicoptère
ils savent que les deux gangsters n'ont
maintenant plus rien à perdre
colonel janet vous êtes avec nous ce
soir vous est répartie de la direction
de la gendarmerie
on a affaire ici à un vraiment un crime
gratuit absolument gratuit puisque les
cédantes fer pouvaient s'emparer des
véhicules sans tuer leur leur professeur
et il pouvait ne pas tirer sur ce
gendarme qui ne l'est mais ne menaçait
pas il était par mais non vous possédez
d'un signalement mon colonel
parfaitement et il a été largement
diffusée les recherches se poursuivent
activement et j'espère qu'elles
aboutiront
non point de vue plus général on
insistait semble-t-il à une augmentation
de la criminalité dans les campagnes et
dans les petites villes comment
l'expliquez vous
il ne faut pas croire que les criminels
sont togo tournant des gens qui habite
justement les campagnes et les petites
villes ce sont des bandes organisées
dans les grandes zones urbaines et
suburbaines qui souvent viennent quand
il met leur exploit à l'occasion des
défaites ou tout simplement viennent il
y ait une banque vous avez son petit
bout une augmentation de la criminalité
dans les campagnes de la violence dans
les campagnes dans la violence d'avoir
nous l'avons ressenti et dans la
gendarmerie
une façon très nette puisque en 75 nous
avons eu à peu près cent trente cinq
gendarmes blessés dans ces
circonstances-là en 76 155 et pour le
premier semestre de 77 nous en avons
déjà eu 120 comment expliquez vous cette
progression la criminalité dans les
campagnes et bien il y as pour les
et jeunes désoeuvrés il y a d'abord
l'appât de l'argent facile et puis aussi
la recherche de l'exploit à l'exploit
criminels qui est un exploit pour un
exploit comme un autre et on tire on tue
simplement pour épater les copains
vous pensez que les zones jan aps les
gangsters qui ont tué les deux personnes
font partie de ses gonds concernant je
pense mais l'avenir
j'apporte relâché et précision simon
connaissent avant dernière étape du tour
de france de l'emploi pour monsieur
raymond barre un tour de france qui se
terminera demain à toulouse aujourd'hui
le premier ministre était à charleville
mézières au coeur d'une région
particulièrement touchée par le chômage
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de problèmes
ici at il expliqué devant la commission
de l'emploi régional cet après midi
raymond barre n'a pas manqué de rappeler
qu'il est devenu premier ministre il ya
un an exactement le 25 août 1976 et que
depuis il s'est battu dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles
les gens adorent les anniversaires et en
ce qui me concerne je crois que ce qui
est important c'est la continuité d'une
action
je vous dirai simplement ceci beaucoup
pensent quand l'économie
il est possible de faire des miracles
or les miracles n'existent pas en
économie
les miracles sont le résultat d'une
action globale patiente et continue
c'est ce que j'ai entrepris de faire
lorsque j'ai été nommé premier ministre
il y a un an je voudrais aujourd'hui que
l'on n'oublie pas quelle était la
situation à la fin d'août 1976 en ce
jour anniversaire raymond barre peut
s'estimer satisfait pour la première
fois depuis le début de
tour de france entre lille sow masquer
le premier ministre a eu l'occasion de
s'entretenir avec des délégués de la cgt
de la cfdt et de la fen de plus toutes
les organisations syndicales avaient
décidé de rencontrer le chef du
gouvernement
ensemble dialogues bien sûr sans
concession mais dialogue malgré tout
même si les syndicats et des motifs
particuliers ici dans les ardennes pour
rencontrer monsieur bart le 28 avril une
action importante réorganisation
syndicats se sont engagés devant les
travailleurs a rencontré le premier
ministre pour exposer la situation
c'est dans le cadre de cette demande
premier ministre reçoit aujourd'hui et
non dans le cadre de son tour de france
une invitation particulière à l'occasion
de son tour de il faut dire que les
ardennes sont un des départements
français les plus touchés par le chômage
à l'heure actuelle le premier ministre
s'en est inquiété mais au corps et sa
conférence de presse il a tenu avant
tout à expliciter ses propos de colmar
sur le chômage des jeunes tout le monde
ne mérite pas l'effort de solidarité
nationale prônée par le gouvernement
cette solidarité entre les générations
que le gouvernement veut promouvoir
suppose que certains ne tente pas
systématiquement pour des raisons
politiques de faire échouer les mesures
prises ou encore que de faux chômeurs
même si leur nombre est limité
n'essaie pas d'abuser de la collectivité
nationale
les français savent qu'il existe de deux
faux demandeurs d'emploi ils en ont une
expérience quotidienne
ceci n'est pas tolérable commerçants
artisans et industriels ce petit livre
vert vous intéresse si vous êtes à la
veille d'un contrôle fiscal
et si vous vous demandez qui peut me
contrôler quels sont les pouvoirs du
contrôleur quels sont mes droits aussi
est ce que par exemple je dois le
laisser visiter mon appartement
ne vous tracassez plus toutes les
réponses ou presque sont dans ce petit
opuscule préparer entre autres par le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
pour tout renseignement vous adresser à
la direction départementale de la
concurrence et des prix la préparation
des élections législatives
rouge c'est bien ce n'est pas pour tout
de suite mais finalement tous les débats
dans la majorité dans l'opposition sont
surtout axés vers ce but
élément nouveau à propos de
l'actualisation du programme commun le
jugement de françois ceyrac le patron
des patrons au micro de france inter
en attaquant mitterrand les communistes
font passer les socialistes pour des
gens rassurant tout en faisant plaisir à
leurs propres militants
il s'agit là d'une combinaison
astucieuse a dit monsieur serra jean
françois kahn est ce que vous pensez
vraiment que toutes ces controverses
déroule simplement pour amuser la
galerie écoutez si les communistes ont
pris l'initiative d'un vaste débat géré
même d'une polémique au sein de la
gauche et qui portent sur des problèmes
de fond sur les problèmes sérieux ce
n'est pas simplement pour amuser les
estivants au mois d'août d'ailleurs il
ya plus amusant ça c'est le premier
point
si l'on fait donc c'est qu'il avait des
raisons sérieuses de leur point de vue
de le faire
deuxième point on dit souvent on bat
comme vous dites ils font c'est un peu
pour amuser la galerie on va faire
monter les enchères et puis le 15
septembre tout le monde va
retrouvez aux tentes et autour d'un
programme commun plus ou moins actualisé
et embrassons-nous folleville soit 10 a
débuté voilà or ce n'est absolument pas
évident
ce n'est pas évident je vais vous dire
pourquoi il faut remonter un petit peu
en arrière
à l'origine c'est les communistes qui
ont voulu pour l'âme commun qui ont fait
campagne pour le problème comme je
dirais même qu'ils ont un peu imposé un
parti socialiste n'était pas très chaud
sur la méthode alors beaucoup de gens
ont dit à l'époque souvenez-vous des
commentateurs très sérieux ça va faire
le jeu du parti communiste il va être le
grand gagnant dans cette affaire
peut-être des conditions telles pensées
aussi je ne sais pas or qu'est ce qu'on
a vu alors on a vu que ce sont les
socialistes qui ont été les grands
gagnants
c'est bien simple un an ou deux ans
avant le programme commun les
communistes avaient deux points d'avancé
sur les socialistes aujourd'hui si on en
croit les sondages et sa styliste aurait
dix points d'avancé sur les communes
bien alors les communistes énorme allons
analyser cette situation ils se sont
interrogés
pourquoi comment ça se fait et alors ils
se sont aperçus de quoi sont aperçus de
cela c'est que si les communistes
avaient 25 24 26 % des voix jusqu'à
présent c'est que beaucoup d'électeurs
votaient pour le seul parti vraiment de
gauche
ce ça voulait pas dire qu'ils étaient
pour une société communiste qu'ils
étaient martys même le parti qui
vraiment proposer des solutions de
gauche
un changement de société les socialistes
si c'était fait la guerre en algérie et
c'est bien là dessus programme commun
alors il ya eu tellement de différences
entre socialistes et communistes ils
disent la même chose et beaucoup de
lecteurs qui votait communistes se sont
dits bas puisque les socialistes et les
communistes est pareil puisqu'ils ont le
même programme puisqu'il nous propose la
même chose pourquoi ne pas voter
socialiste
peut-être même est plus efficace voilà
ce que les communistes se sont aperçus
autrement dit se sont aperçus que ce qui
faisait leur force leur originalité
c'était un peu diluée dans un ensemble
on les reconnaît ses plaies donc ils
veulent aujourd'hui réagir voilà se
donner de nouveaux une originalité
montrer qu'ils ne sont pas comme les
autres qui restent grands partis de la
gauche et que les socialistes on a parti
réformiste et modérée alors c'est
pourquoi si vous voulez c'est pourquoi
le 15 septembre
d'abord il est fort peu probable que
socialiste communiste sed sur des points
essentiels
mais surtout il est très possible que
programme réactualisé ou pas ça je ne
sais pas il reste des points de
désaccord essentiel qu'il soit même
officialiser ce qui permettrait au parti
communiste sur
certains points au moins de se battre
sur ses propres options au premier tour
des élections bien sûr puisqu'on
deuxième on s'entendra désistera mais au
premier tour de se base sur ses propres
options sur ses propres idées et sur ses
propres propositions sur certains points
donc un sommet de septembre
particulièrement important à l'étranger
à retenir d'abord à propos du
proche-orient la déclaration monsieur
valdaï le secrétaire général des nations
unies les palestiniens de l'ol paie
yasser arafat sont prêtes à accepter la
résolution 242 si elle reconnaissait
cette résolution le droit pour les
palestiniens à avoir un état pour le
leader palestinien yasser arafat ce que
l'on voit ici avec le ministre égyptien
des affaires étrangères
ce serait une concession extrêmement
importante est la preuve de la volonté
palestinienne d'engager par les états
unis interposés un dialogue véritable
avec israël en effet selon monsieur
valdaï mme l'ol paie serait prête à
reconnaître l'existence d'israël
si israël reconnaît le droit des
palestiniens à se créer une patrie
si cette information était confirmée par
le conseil central de l'olp et qui se
réunit depuis aujourd'hui à damas
toutes les données du problème du
moyen-orient en seraient bouleversés
pourtant on voit toujours mal comment
israël qui a toujours refusé de
dialoguer avec l'ol paie ou d'admettre
la création d'une patrie palestinienne
juste répondre favorablement à cette
initiative de yasser arafat
monsieur venance le secrétaire d'état
américain quittera demain matin pékin
sans avoir obtenu de résultats très
spectaculaire en fait c'était assez
prévu il était surtout question pour
monsieur ventes de présenter aux
autorités chinoises le programme de
politique étrangère du président carter
sulfure de bonnes conversations
exploratoire a expliqué monsieur hakuho
fang que monsieur frantz a rencontré
aujourd'hui dans l'ensemble la chine et
les états unis ont quand même fait
apparemment quelques progrès pour la
normalisation de leurs relations
dezeen est toujours pas question de
faire varier cette fameuse caisse fameux
problème de taiwan l'autre chine le
ministère le ministre italien de la
défense a toujours bien du mal à
expliquer à la chambre des députés et à
son opinion publique il n'est pas
responsable de l'évasion de l'ancien
colonel ss kappler les accusations vont
bon train contre lui et le gouvernement
et jusqu'à maintenant ce sont les
carabiniers chargés de la surveillance
de l'ancien ss qui porte le chapeau dans
cette affaire ils sont responsables
je ne veux pas en démordre continue de
répéter à longueur de journée devant le
parlement italien
le ministre le vatican pour sa part
regrette toutes ces polémiques entre les
partis politiques italiens et constate
que cela ne sert pas les relations entre
l'italie et l'allemagne fédérale
l' affaire est close dit-on à rome
aujourd'hui dans les milieux catholiques
en allemagne fédérale aussi il semble
bien en particulier dans la ville de
salt à eau où s'est réfugié l'ancien
chef de la gestapo de rome il semble
bien que tout le monde veuille aussi
tourner la page
entre hambourg et hanovre dans le nord
de l'allemagne
seul temps est redevenu une petite ville
comme les autres
après les manifestations et l'agitation
de la semaine dernière la vie a repris
son cours normal
la maison d'anne lise cas plaire les
pousses du criminel de guerre a retrouvé
son anonymat des enfants ont pris la
place des journalistes et des policiers
sur les trottoirs avoisinant la
guérisseuse analyses capillaires a
disparu ses clients attendent le
garagiste local est heureux que le calme
soit revenu
depuis samedi dernier déjà dit il après
des manifestations communistes et autres
pour lui ce remue ménage n'aura pas été
très payant qu'il n'a pas eu plus de
clients pour autant al'inverse le
fleuriste de salt en a fait de bonnes
affaires
chaque jour des dizaines de télégrammes
et envoi de fleurs sont arrivés chez lui
afin qu'il les transmette à herbert et
analyses capillaires pour cet homme dont
la mère anti nazi a été alternée deux
ans dans un camp de concentration
les pousses de herbert kappler mérite
son respect il estime par ailleurs que
cap l'air doit être laissé en paix de
façon quasi unanime les habitants de
soltau sont de même avis
jusqu aux plus jeunes qui eux aussi
trouvent justifiés que cap l'air soit un
seul camp car nous dit on ici qu'à
plaire n'est pas responsable il n'a fait
qu'exécuter des genres dont et puis
ajoute notre dos laissant les italiens
on s'en débarrasser en attendant pour
beaucoup de monde la maison qu'à plaire
n'a pas dévoilé son secret depuis une
semaine on croit que cap leers est
abritée derrière ses rideaux
en fait il n'en est rien à ne vise qu'à
plaire à cacher le bourreau de romans
lieu sûr
amaigri et s'étant laissé pousser la
barbe cas plaire se trouve actuellement
dans la région de soltau dans une maison
aménagée en prix unique de fortune
sa femme le soignent du cancer par
l'homéopathie cap l'air continue de
bénéficier du soutien moral et matériel
d'amis influents mais le criminel de
guerre mourant reste un homme traqué
l'énergie nucléaire si l'on peut dire
qu'il ya eu un avant et un après créé
smallville pour le combat des
écologistes on peut remarquer depuis
hier soir georges leclercq que la
réflexion sur le problème du nucléaire
ne sera plus tout à fait la même depuis
la diffusion de notre magazine sur
antenne 2 oui et côté c'est presque
pareil
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement pensait
que finalement le nucléaire c'est une
question technique y laisser faire dans
les techniciens il fallait quarante
mille mégawatts d'énergie prévus pour
1985 une centrale comme celles ci ont
fait à peu près 1000
il faut donc 40 central où elle quelques
était très simple df était le roi il
décider ce qu'il voulait en fonction
bien sûr du plan du gouvernement depuis
hier soir ce n'est plus tout à fait cela
monsieur rené monory nous a bien fait
comprendre que le recours au nucléaire
impliqué un choix de la société où nous
allons vivre dans dix ans comme le
nucléaire est très centralisateur
puisqu'une seule centrale de ce type
peut apporter l'énergie pour toute une
région
eh bien il n'est plus question bien au
contraire du tout nucléaire
alors bien sûr de prime abord monsieur
me nourris nous a dit pas de moratoire
pas d'arrêt maintenant le rythme de
construction mais il ajoute le nucléaire
doit avoir sa place parmi les autres
énergies il doit jouer un rôle
honnêtement sans secret c'est pourquoi
par exemple il promet d'ouvrir tous les
dossiers au futur conseil de
l'information nucléaire
concrètement le ministre nous a même
donné un exemple hier soir celui de
l'eau chaude exemple déjà appliquée dans
beaucoup de pays européens
voici une centrale nucléaire représenté
ici
voilà comment elle fonctionne ici c'est
le réacteur la partie atomique
la turbine ici récupère l'eau chaude qui
vient du réacteur qui était chauffée
c'est de l'eau sous pression qui est
environ à 3 ou 400 degrés
cette eau fait tourner la turbine
produit de l'électricité et l'eau une
fois refroidie à 30° rejetée par ici en
gros c'est le principe des centrales
modernes comme celle ci comme fessenheim
est bien l'énergie produite par le
réacteur est en gros divisé en deux un
tiers est convertie en électricité
les deux autres tiers sont perdue
gaspillée et c'est cela que monsieur
maunoury veut éviter il déposera donc en
octobre un projet de loi pour récupérer
l'eau chaude rejetée par cette centrale
mais cette eau chaude les rejeter à 30°
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec des lois
trop
mais si la question peut se poser bah
pas grand chose parce qu'on perd cette
température si on veut transporter l'eau
un peu plus loin alors des ingénieurs
proposent autre chose ont fait
pratiquement la même turbines mais en
faisant un tout petit peu moins
d'électricité
on prélève l'eau à 100° ya 100 degrés
vous pouvez chauffer des maisons
chauffées des usines chauffer des
immeubles on peut s'en servir dans
l'industrie bref au lieu de tirer un tir
de l'énergie produite par la centrale
est de jeter deux tiers on en tire
pratiquement 90 %
vous croyez que c'est du rêve ça existe
déjà en europe
je voulais donner un cas français la
communauté de lille roubaix tourcoing
possède une grande compagnie qui
s'appelle la compagnie de chauffe qui
vend du chauffage elle distribue de
l'eau chaude à travers des immeubles ici
il n'ya pas très loin une centrale en
construction gravelines si on appliquait
ce nouveau procédé à gravelines en pour
échauffer dunkerque calais boulogne et
probablement toute cette communauté
ça changerait déjà beaucoup
l'orientation du programme nucléaire
cela évitera gaspillage considérable et
cela au moment où on parle d'économie
d'énergie merci georges leclercq
quelques petits problèmes en perspective
pour ceux qui doivent prendre l'avion
dans les jours à venir je vais essayer
de résumer toutes les informations que
nous avons ce soir
soyons fair-play d'abord commençons par
la situation en grande bretagne grève
générale à partir de minuit ce soir sur
tous les aéroports britanniques pour
tous les contrôleurs aériens
la grève va durer quatre jours après
d'ultimes négociations sur les salaires
l'année dernière aucun accord n'est
intervenu entre le gouvernement et les
représentants du syndicat des
aiguilleurs du ciel britannique grève
générale donc pendant quatre jours cette
grève ne devrait pas toucher les vols
d'air france pour londres
en dehors de quelques petits retards air
france a assuré tous ses vols
aujourd'hui aller retour pour la
capitale britannique
et cela continuera même pendant la grève
situation en france maintenant les
contrôleurs aériens cftc vont donc
déclencher une grève du zèle du 26 août
au 5 septembre grève du zèle
c'est à dire à prévoir non pas des
annulations de vols mais quelques petits
retards qui peuvent aller le disons de
15 à 20 minutes air inter de toute façon
assurera tous ces retours sur terre
au son des tam-tams avec le retour de
bison futé et surtout la rentrée au
foyer de près de 4 millions
d'automobiles
le week-end prochain finies les vacances
il y a déjà eu des bouchons hier sur la
nationale 10 et sur la nationale 9
millions futé devra donc faire flèche de
tout bois pendant les trois jours à
venir
alors le rappel des heures à éviter pour
mieux circuler dans la mesure du
possible évitez ces trois jours cruciaux
vendredi samedi dimanche par ces sois
plus tard le lundi 29 soit plus tôt que
jeudi 25 c'est à dire ce soir
bison futé vous déconseille les départs
de 6 à 12 heures voire de 6 à 15 pour la
région méditerranéenne et pour franchir
la frontière espagnole
essayez de prendre la route très tôt le
matin avant 6 heures dans l'après-midi
ou en soirée
ou encore si la météo le permettent dans
la nuit mais n'oubliez pas de faire des
états dimanche présente sensiblement
moins de difficultés enfin si vous
quittez le centre n'attendez pas
l'arrivée des autres par ses taux dans
la médecine
deux autre télégramme encore concernant
l'automobile les quatre constructeurs
français d'automobiles sans vie de
chrysler simca citroën peugeot et
renault viennent d'annoncer que la
garantie automobile pièces et main
d'oeuvre sans limitation de kilométrage
passe de six à douze mois pour leurs
voitures neuves
et puis jean pierre fourcade a présenté
hier le budget de l'équipement pour 1978
les autoroutes sont une de ses priorités
parmi les sections qui seront mises en
service l'an prochain les tronçons
narbonne riddes à la ferté bernard le
mans besançon ces chiens narbonne
carcassonne et clermont ferrand tiers
les voici tous ces secteurs mis en
service l'année prochaine au total près
de 400 km d'autoroute de liaison seront
donc achevée l'an prochain en province
anniversaire de la libération de paris
aujourd'hui le 33e depuis ce matin
plusieurs cérémonies se sont déjà
déroulées une messe à notre-dame et des
dépôts de gerbe à l'hôtel de ville à la
mémoire des fonctionnaires fusillés
pendant l'occupation
depuis quelques minutes une autre
cérémonie vient de commencer près de la
porte d'orléans devant le monument du
maréchal leclerc bernard pradines au
vous êtes sur place
la première cérémonie vient de se
terminer la première cérémonie de la
soirée le maire de paris a déposé
une gerbe au pied de la statue du
maréchal leclerc il était accompagné de
madame de hauteclocque la statue du
maréchal leclerc et place du 25 août à
la porte d'orléans
la deuxième cérémonie aura lieu dans
quelques instants à montparnasse place
du 18 juin 1940 les militaires les jeeps
les chars à mx et la musique de la
marine sont en train de défiler entre la
porte d'orléans et montparnasse
monsieur chirac va déposer une gerbe là
où le général allemand von choltitz a
remis sa reddition
et ce soir dans une heure autre
cérémonie à l'hôtel de ville après que
les cloches des églises parisiennes et
sonnait tout ensemble à 21h à pradines
où ces cérémonies ont quand même
provoqué quelques polémiques disant oui
la fédération parisienne du parti
socialiste conteste la célébration de la
libération de paris les socialistes
disent monsieur chirac poursuite en fait
un but électoral la fédération de paris
du parti communiste proteste également
en disant que c'est la population
parisienne qui s'est soulevé et qu'on ne
parle que de la 2e db du général leclerc
les communistes ajoute von choltitz
s'est rendu au général leclerc et au
colonel rol-tanguy chef militaire des
forces françaises de l'intérieur des ffi
pour l'île de france
or le colonel rol-tanguy ne participe
pas aux cérémonies et cela n'est pas
normal
voilà pour la contestation un mode et
cérémonie à l'hôtel de ville après 21h
21h15 revue des troupes puis discours du
président de la 2e db monsieur pitcho
discours de monsieur chirac discours de
monsieur porte secrétaire d'état aux
anciens combattants
ensuite spectacle audiovisuel de 10
minutes avec projection d'image de la
libération de paris avec un procédé
spécial un canon qui projette sans écran
sur une surface de 3000 m² enfin vers 10
heures du soir feu d'artifice tricolore
tiré du pont d'arcole au son du chant
des partisans
par la musique des gardiens de la paix 1
33e anniversaire de la libération de
paris célébrée vous le voyez avec
effectivement beaucoup de fast y est un
tiers c'est cet après midi à vincennes
dans la 5e course
il a été remporté par lots fans le 16
suivi de iron ii d'avril le 2 et de
haut-brion le 15
voici pour 5 francs les rapports de ce
tiercé de vincennes
et puis en football hier soir plus que
le résultat la france a battu hambourg
par 4 buts à 2 c'était la manière qu'ils
comptaient michel hidalgo n'a pas été
satisfait à 100% mais les 45000
spectateurs
présent apparemment eux ont apprécié le
spectacle un nom est revenue sans arrêt
celui du roi du parc des princes hier
soir il s'agissait de michel platini
et voici des images de s'asseoir et de
galles keller a ouvert la marque pour
hambourg
c'est alors que michel platini commence
un contre favorable
un petit point en pleine course un
centre parfait et paix fut également en
vue depuis vingt réunis une faute de nos
glee sur ce même pécout va valoir à
l'équipe de france un coup franc
coup franc tiré par l'ailier gauche de
saint-etienne christian sarramagna très
bon lui aussi hier soir et vous allez
voir un homme sauter plus haut que tout
le monde à la manière de trésors à
maracana
cet homme c'est toujours le numéro 10
michel platini
2 blizzard et ça n'est pas fini car le
point d'orgue va venir dans quelques
instants à la suite d'une nouvelle
attaque tricolore des tricolores qui
furent excellents surtout dans la
deuxième partie de cette première mi
temps sur ce centre nogi dégage de la
tête
latinier la contrôle du pied droit
frappe instantanée du pied gauche un but
à vire le plus beau de la soirée 3 à 1
c'est la mi temps
en deuxième mi-temps reihman ramène
hambourg à 3 2 c'est alors qu'à six
minutes de la fin
platini marque son troisième but de la
soirée sur une action menée par baptiste
on est d'alger
michel platini le milieu rural équipe de
france prometic
est ce qu'on parle de moi n'est pas très
important il faut qu'on parle de
l'équipe de france parce que c'est quand
même l'équipe de france passe au genre
et battu l'équipe d'hambourg est quand
même marqué trois buts michel votre
modestie dut-elle en souffrir et vous
avez fait marquer le 4e certes j'ai
marqué trois buts mais j'ai profité un
peu du travail obscur de certains jours
du milieu de terrain est aussi travaillé
un temps des attaquants que je sois au
départ ou à l'arrivée le principal c'est
qu'on marque un but depuis ce que nos
adversaires et crier tout ce qu'on dit
sur vous et à propos de boue michel
platini ça vous gêne au ca me crispe un
peu parce qu'on a beau répéter toujours
les mêmes choses ce sont toujours les
mêmes faits qui reviennent ce sont
toujours des histoires de transfert le
problème il est simple c'est que je suis
à nancy cette année et que l'année
prochaine je vais voir je ne sais pas où
j'irai peut-être sûrement je resterai
nancy mais pour l'instant je suis dans
dans la tente
vous savez que tout le monde et les
50000 spectateurs du parc des princes
hier qui ont scandé votre nom le
souhaite je dois vous le dire on
souhaite que vous restiez en france
aussi je souhaite rester en france parce
que ce football étranger est très
difficile surtout pour un français qui
s'expatrient reste c'est beaucoup plus
difficile que publiques françaises d'un
démon non hier au parc c'est très beau
je suis très fier mais c'est qu'il ya
c'est que dans les prochains matchs
faudrait il se trouve toujours que je
suis bon et c'est ce qui est très
difficile dans le football
deux mots de la météo pour terminer ce
journal vendredi lire encore des pluies
et des orages isolés dans le sud et
l'est de la france
partout ailleurs le temps sera variable
avec des éclaircies qui alterneront avec
de la pluie sur le sud et le sud-est les
averses seront moins nombreuses quand
même
les vents seront assez fort à fort près
des côtes de l'embouchure de la charente
à la mer du nord
retrouver hélène vida pour la dernière
édition du journal vers 23h50 après le
grand échiquier
mais je ne voudrais pas vous quitter
sans vous confirmer l'une des nouvelles
de toutes façons les plus importants de
cette journée les fiançailles
officielles de la princesse caroline de
monaco avec monsieur philippe junot ils
s'étaient connus à paris chez des amis
communs au mois de décembre 1975
ils se sont revus souvent cupidon a fait
le reste
ils se sont donc fiancée la bague est un
saphir serti de diamants toute simple
mariage prévu en juin 1978 nous serons
encore là et nous vous tiendrons au
courant
c'est promis meilleurs voeux de bonheur
et belle soirée